- Do it, put it in your mouth,
and it pops in your mouth.
- Oh no, I'm scared, I don't know.
- No no, really, it's so much fun.
(Galen laughs)
(gags)
(laughter)
(upbeat music)
- I know what that thing is.
- I know the thing!
It's from the movie--
- Furby?
Furby thingie?
- Is it like a Gremlin?
- Looks like a Furby
thing and you like press,
it's a kid's toy.
- Oh, it's scary.
- It's really creepy
- And then they grow
and they get older, and bigger,
and then that movie where it was like--
- That's the Gremlins.
- No I think it's, I genuinely
do think it's the Gremlin.
- Is it a Gremlin Furby?
- Is it a Gremlin?
- Yeah!
[Woman] - It's a Furby.
- I said Furby.
Whoo!
- For real?
(upbeat music)
- Ohhh!
- Ohh!
- What is it?
(bracelet snaps)
- I was just about to do that.
- [Galen] Got it!
- Those things that snap on your wrist.
- These are great chokers, guys.
- [Galen] Yeah, that's not
what they're for Millie.
(upbeat music)
- What is this?
- It's like Silly String goo.
(all gasp)
- Oh my God, no way.
- Goo.
- Little bebe!
- I saw the--
- This my new--
- I saw that it said, like,
that weird like, Gak?
[Caleb] - Yeah, Gak!
- That stuff's nasty!
- Gonna have a cheesburger!
- Super string!
- It sounds like a type of like, burp
that you have that's like, really
nasty--
- Oh, it's like--
[Woman] - Mille, what do
you think it's called?
- The slime from the upside down.
(upbeat music
- What is it? I mean, what does it do?
- Do it, put it in your mouth,
and it pops in your mouth.
- Oh no, I'm scared, I don't--
- No, no, really!
- No, no.
- It's so much fun.
(upbeat music)
(Galen laughs)
(gags)
(laughter)
- Oh!
Oh!
Oh, no!
(Galen laughs)
- It's supposed to do that, don't worry.
- They need to leave my mouth.
Right now.
(sings) Ahhhhh!
(Galen harmonizing) Ahhhh! Ah! Ahhhhhh!
(Caleb harmonizing) Ahhhh!!
(all singing harmony)
[Woman] - Beautiful.
(upbeat music)
(sign squeaks)